we've seen some significant donations
from time to time by nfl owners coaches
players etc i can't recall five million
dollars being devoted by any one person
drew brees saints quarterback giving
five million along with his wife
brittany to the state of louisiana to
combat the issues arising from
the covet 19 pandemic
unbelievable gesture and
you know these are things that we like
to spotlight peter because to the extent
that it can inspire others of similar or
greater means to do the same thing
hopefully they will five million i was
blown away by that one
you know and i think one of the things i
i thought immediately of mike is that in
the in the wake of katrina
uh i will never forget going in and
writing about drew brees for sports
illustrated a couple of years later
where he and a group of 10 business
people in new orleans
got together two or three times a year
and they all put in twenty five thousand
dollars which later grew to fifty
and they all basically said okay what
projects that were ruined by this storm
are we going to support and get back on
their feet and every year they would
basically resuscitate
four or five things that had died in new
orleans and i remember i went to one of
these uh dinners that brees had these
dinner meetings
at commander's palace in new orleans and
i remember walking out of there that
night with brees and he said to me he
goes
if we're not going to do it who is
and that is the ethos of drew brees he
understands that you know he has got
sick ridiculous money and so what is he
going to do leave bailin 200 000 less
the day he dies no he's gonna leave
baylen his son
an example of how you live your life
when you have something
and you have a lot it's your
responsibility to give back to the
people who are needy
and let me also say this we don't know
how much longer drew brees is going to
play football we don't know what he's
going to do when he's done he has told
me in the past he likes he's going to
want to do several different things of
all the guys who have ever played in the
nfl who had political aspirations i know
jack kemp ran for president brees is the
one guy peter that i think can pull it
off and ultimately be the president of
the united states if that's something he
wants to do and something not only not
only can't not only can pull it off not
only can pull it off but in my opinion
will attempt to pull it off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports